here in indianapolis the scouting
combine joining us now the general
manager of the minnesota vikings one of
the final eight teams in 2019 after a
thrilling overtime win over the new
orleans saints in the wild card round
he's rick spielman rick great to see you
as always
[Music]
you know the over under was three
seconds and at the under you know that i
mean come on this is great i love this
you guys you guys have been
close
the past few years
is that
is that like almost worse than than
than being not even in the conversation
to be close enough where you feel like
you got a shot and it just
you can't grab the brass ring yeah and i
think every year you know we look at how
we can potentially tweak things to
finally get us you know not at the
doorstep but actually get into the big
game and hopefully win that
um and i know this year you know coach
zim analyzing some of the things from a
coaching staff standpoint what we're
going to do differently i think it's uh
big that gary kubiak steps in in kevin
stefanski's place who i think will do a
phenomenal job in cleveland uh to be our
offensive coordinator and i think you
know
the continuity on offense with kirk
cousins actually playing in a same
offensive system the second year in a
row right it's also something which you
know is big
uh and then some of the changes on you
know with them freshening up maybe some
new ideas on the defensive side and how
we can get better on that side i love
the dom capers higher i mean a 3-4 guy
coming in with a 4-3 system it just
shows a willingness to be flexible that
a lot of coaches
of mike zimmer's age
aren't going to want to do right well i
think that's what makes coach zim so
unique is because no one has an ego in
the building everybody's trying to get
to the ultimate goal so
whatever
we have to do
to put the egos aside
um because we're all going to benefit if
we do win that game and uh so we're
going to assess where we're at every
year and bring in the top talent that we
can and thank
uh want to thank the ownership because
they give us the resources to do that as
well because if you don't have the
ownership they can give you the
resources to bring in the top talent not
only on the field but also the coaches
uh then you're not going to be able to
do a lot of things that we've done
kirk cousins i mean that's the that's
the guy that we always talk about kirk
cousins
or he likes chicago
kirk i said kirk i'm always respectful
but yeah but but talk about his year
just what it did for him the
organization everything around it i
think when you see from year one and
then when kubiak and stefanski took over
and did things that he does well and
it's established in the run game this
outside zone uh the play action i think
when he is kept clean in the pocket and
he has time he is one of the most
accurate quarterbacks throwing in this
league definitely now at all levels at
the short level to intermittent level
and and even downfield deep level
i think you know
the biggest knock on him a lot was can
he win in big games yeah and i think
you've seen for the first time this year
to go into dallas and win on prime time
game on the road they stun wasn't a big
game
the saints game was huge though but you
gotta even just take the denver game
okay we're down 25 at halftime right and
because of the way kirk cousins played
uh he brought us back i think he threw
three touchdowns uh to bring us back in
the second half well i don't know if
we've been able to do that in the past
so you see the progress that he's made
you have a a gary kubiak a coach that
that that truly believes in his
abilities and what he can do with this
guy
uh and i think it's only going to be
going up from there because right now at
his age they're right in the prime of
their career and i still think there's
going to be huge improvements and you
see him take the next step next year
here's my assessment of how i think he
needs to take the next step and i don't
know that it can be feel free to block
your ears at any point okay whatever you
want i want to be serious i want to be
serious about this and i want to be
straight with you about it
i think that when the walls close in the
play falls apart that he doesn't have
the mobility
to get away
from the pass rush right and i don't
know what you can do in an offseason to
make a guy better adept to to escape and
extend a play but is that that's not an
unfair criticism no but you're
what you're you're you have to
understand what his strengths are now if
we want to go to
a scramble quarterback that is not as
accurate that may not fit the system as
well
then is that what you're saying but i
think if we do some things to maybe
improve even up front
some of the things that we're doing up
front and some of the personnel i think
we have two really good young
cornerstone offensive linemen and we'll
continue to to build that area and to
get him on the boots and the play action
there's a lot of very good quarterbacks
in this league uh that that don't have
the ability to make plays on their feet
and a lot of them guys are going to be
in the hall of fame at one time well
yeah yeah
yes you're right and i'd like to sit
here and argue with him about some of
the things
he's invited he's sucking up well no i'm
not going to i want to be like it's not
always about the quarterback and the
mobility i mean tom brady can't move for
crap kirk cousins beats him in a race
all the time he's got a great old line
great pass protection and helps out
that's all i was going to say and it's a
great system i mean how many how many
years has he been in that same system
for 20 i mean this whole time the guy
over there charlie weiss is sitting
right over there who taught it but my
point is if we have someone up front if
a
blo we pick failed to pick up a blitz or
of an offensive lineman we say get beat
quickly where as soon as he gets back he
has someone in his face is that his
fault that he can't escape now i'm
saying there are things sometimes that
you know looks like everybody if you
want to try to pick things that he can
improve on maybe using his legs a little
more because he is
has enough mobility to make some plays
with his feet right um but his strength
is the play action and when we do the
play action we get the running game
going that gives us a little bit more
time and gives him a little bit more
time to do the things he does best all
right let me ask you this are you going
to try to extend his contract are you
going to let him play out the funnel you
know we we're we're went through all of
our meetings i'll never talk about the
business perspective of because we have
a lot of tough decisions to make on a
lot of our roster
some of our guys are getting older
we have a lot of you know unrestricted
free agents that we'd love to keep but
are we able to keep them i think the one
thing that we've been able to do is
there are a lot of young guys on our
roster maybe not had the opportunity to
play yet but because of the way our
coaches develop this young talent that
they step in an example of being anthony
harris yeah who waited his turn waited
his turn all sudden he got his
opportunity to start and he became one
of the the top safeties in my opinion in
the league last year right so we have a
lot of guys i think that uh that that
are in the wings that that will be able
to step up if we have to make some tough
roster decisions but you when you're
planning you're also playing okay if
we're able to extend kirk cousins and i
know how the coaching staff feels about
them i don't know how we feel about them
what are we able to do then to improve
our roster from last year right to maybe
finally get to over the threshold where
you want oh i want to go into your you
know i mean this is a big year for you
guys i mean first off you guys have a
problem because last year i mean every
year is a big year but there's a lot
more decisions to be doing that's what i
mean that's what i do and a lot of it is
because of your doing you've drafted so
well that you have this homegrown talent
that you want to pay but it's hard to
let them walk out the door so that's a
credit to you but yeah i mean where does
this start everything griffin trey
wayne's mackenzie alexander anthony
harris like you just talked about dalvin
cook's on the horizon i mean how do you
attack these are things you know as you
go through and
you know after you go through your
buckets of evaluating your roster
evaluating the free agent market
evaluating the draft where the strengths
and weaknesses are how you're going to
fill the needs can you fill the needs
but also you got to layer in the
financial piece where we're at from a
cap standpoint our ownership has always
never said no on the financial piece of
us being able to extend these young guys
but guys do get older guys do phase out
you can't always keep everyone so you're
hoping that you have some guys in the
wings like the anthony harris when they
get their opportunities uh that they
step up and fill in and hopefully i i
truly believe that i have a great staff
around me and george payton and rob
brzezinski and yeah and the coaches uh
that we all work very well together that
to keep that continuity and keep moving
forward all right last one it's not a
question it's a request oh gosh in honor
of the seven year anniversary of the
percy harvin trade i want you to look
into the camera and say we have no
intent to trade stefan diggs
well you do that for me
stefan diggs is a minnesota viking
that's right that's good that meant
absolutely nothing
he is today may not be tomorrow but
that's all right rick spielman thanks
for your time congratulations on the
great year and all the best in 2020
thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports